[Music]
various celebrities were quick to give
their vacuous opinions on national gun
policy in the wake of the parklands
shooting of course famed constitutional
law scholar Chelsea Handler tweeted this
quote we have to elect candidates that
are not funded by the NRA in November we
have an opportunity to elect candidates
who won't allow kids to go to school and
get shot it's disgusting how many times
this has happened and Republicans do
nothing you all have blood on your hands
she said in measured tones meanwhile
elder statesman Kim kardashian-west
tweeted this quote we owe it to our
children and our teachers to keep them
safe while at school prayers won't do
this : action will Congress please do
your job protect Americans from
senseless gun violence that was written
by a publicist you could tell and there
are a lot of other tweets in that same
vein author and columnist mark Stein
specializes in celebrity tweets and Dee
Dee's compiling a book on the subject we
hope and he joins us tonight hey Mark
hey Tucker good to be with you so what
do you make of the response to this well
you know in at a certain level
I understand these idiotic treats
because that the defining act of these
school shootings is is the absence of
meaning I mean if you compare it with
say that Isis guy on the bike path in
New York who mowed down a bunch of
people because he wants to usher in a
new caliphate worldwide in a sense when
you're doing it for Allah that's easier
to understand yes then these completely
empty purposeless events where a guy
just kills a bunch of school kids for no
reason at all and in that vacuum where
we search for meaning people pour their
lamest dreariest tropes and so to blame
it on the NRA is the default position of
most celebrities and most Democrats and
that's what they do but it's but but
it's precisely because there is an
absence of meaning in this event it's
precisely because a guy kills 17 people
for no reason whatsoever nothing to him
that suggests where you said at the top
of the show that the reasons for it a
deeper more complex and it behooves us
in memory of the dead to actually talk
and think seriously about it I agree
with that it's a very deep observation
though about the hollowness at the core
of these things what do you think and
and I I don't know you don't want to
speculate no responsible person does but
you've watched years of this what's your
instinct about some of the causes of it
well for example I mean III think it is
much you talked about social atomization
at the top of the show Tucker and that's
true but the fact is that the
combination of factors means you can be
socially entirely dysfunctional and
actually have a what seems like a rich
and rewarding fantasy life through
technology now you know if you're in the
late 19th century if you were a
miserable social loser
you were basically just on your own
kicking a can around the backyard there
was nothing else to do now like this guy
you can go on the internet you can make
threats that attract the attention of
the FBI apparently you can you can lead
a rewarding life
communicating with some guy in as Becca
Stan or Papua New Guinea all over the
world and in some sense that fantasy
life is more real for people than
actually you know going to the soda
fountain and having a chocolate malt
with friends going 50 60 or years ago
and that's very disturbing that the fact
that the void is now rewarding and
fulfilling there is great peril in that
because it suggests we're gonna have
more of these kind of people in the
years ahead
the effects of Technology we have not
paused long enough to consider what they
are but I suspect you're absolutely
right this is one of them mark Stein
thank you for that really interesting
thanks a lot Tucker